bienvenidos a cultura de france 24
llevamos juntos tres premios nobel de
literatura el de 2018 cuenta a medias
fue aplazado por abusos sexuales y
filtraciones así que no les engañará el
galardón abdul razak urna ha sido
sorpresivo por el desconocimiento
mayoritario de su obra aunque jamás
desconcertante el nivel bob dylan
originario de zanzíbar isla de tanzania
burna lleva desde los 80 dedicado a la
reflexión y la investigación colonial y
post colonial en áfrica el caribe e
india- y es por esta contribución que la
academia sueca de estocolmo ha visto en
él una gran dedicación a la verdad de
los efectos y a la complejidad
en este en sus diez novelas se ha
inmiscuido con gran pasión y de manera
consistente en los efectos del
colonialismo en áfrica oriental y los
efectos de éste en las vidas de los
individuos que dejaron sus raíces y de
quienes migraron
ellos de su trabajo es una imagen vívida
y muy precisa de otra africano tan
conocida para muchos lectores
sobre la esclavitud y formas cambiantes
de represión y distintos regímenes y
poderes coloniales
tras esta distinción hay tres buenas
nuevas
muchos han celebrado tener la
oportunidad de descubrir a un autor más
permitirá que lo poco publicado en
español sea relanzado y lo obvio su
nombre por fin sale de los habituales
occidentales el también profesor y
residente en reino unido- más sonado en
suecia y en los países de la antigua
commonwealth se une así al primer
escritor africano galardonado wole
soyinka y al que desde 1986 sólo
siguieron dos plumas más del continente
cuatro ahora con burn a como decíamos si
bien sus novelas son en inglés precario
silencio paraíso y en la orilla permiten
ya a visitar su hibridación cultural y
la construcción de identidades
poscolonialismo eso sí desde las
poblaciones afectadas
pensé esto es alguien haciéndome una
broma sabes en estos días reciben muchas
llamadas desconocidas y levantas el
teléfono y no sabes quién llama y
alguien te dice has ganado el premio
nobel y piensas o sí
justamente terreno fértil para la
escritura ha sido la obsesión por el
espacio en cine hace más de un siglo
georges méliès moldeo esa idea
estampando un cohete en el ojo derecho
de la luna pero la mujer espacial que
visualizo en 1929 fritz lang no se ha
hecho realidad sino ahora su nombre es
julia pérez il y junto al cineasta clint
chip en coser a la eterna protagonista
del primer filme de ficción grabado en
órbita en concreto de la estación
espacial internacional que servirá de
escenario a una doctora cuya misión es
salvarle la vida a la astronauta y
tripulante real olic nowitzki el reto
cinematográfico sin hermano en el
entrenamiento ni la gravedad es que
varios cosmonautas interpretarán roles
adaptados a sus características y
carácter lo que también puede ser leído
como un desafío título de la cinta o una
nueva carrera entre rusia y eeuu que
anhelaba rodar en el espacio con tom
cruise
sin panteón literario y en temas más
terrenales colombia disfrutó en
presencial el festival de cine francés
que además de festejar 20 años con un
retorno al abrazo físico y a la gran
pantalla permitió en latinoamérica un
pensamiento sobre el rol de los
festivales y el furor actual por la
cinematografía de francia en sólo tres
meses el país se ha alzado con los
máximos galardones de cannes y venecia
usualmente se piensa en los clásicos
franceses como los del fallecido actor
jean paul belmondo pero la realidad
marca una cantidad mayor de cine nuevo
nacional con la producción de 250 a 300
películas por año los últimos años
fueron muy productivos para el cine
francés también y entonces creo que hay
una cantidad enorme de descubrir de
películas por descubrir y nosotros pues
intentamos llevar un porcentaje más
pequeño pero lo mejor del cine francés y
creo que es una experiencia colectiva
que todos necesitamos ya volver a la
presencialidad sí sí sí
en el último san sebastián marion
cotillard explico el porqué de este
éxito fácil si hay diversidad narrativa
es porque existe un gran apoyo del
estado con ayudas transversales por
valor de 1.200 millones de euros pero
eso va en sintonía con la diversidad de
género o vista igual en las ganadoras al
oscar ni a la concha de oro opina la
directora charlene javier que con un
eslalon trata la violencia y el acoso
sexual en el deporte
en francia tenemos muchísimas
realizadoras que están emergiendo yo
entre ellas y eso anima pero luego hay
que seguir apoyando el cine en femenino
[Música]
aún luchamos para conseguir el mismo
salario el mismo presupuesto fílmico
porque todavía no estamos en un 50-50
justamente aunque sí estamos en una
buena es que si sólo a woodward vamos a
volver como despedida desde la cartelera
tres cifras
007 la pandemia vio al 25º james bond
tiempo extra para morir pero daniel cree
no dejó que ni la saga ni su adiós al
esmoquin que utilizó cinco cintas
cayeran por un precipicio de hecho que
su estreno se completará una vez llega
china éste ha tenido la mejor recepción
de la historia de la franquicia aún
cuando se ha instalado la idea de
decepción a los fans el círculo está
claro se cierra son 15 años de cree que
al igual que el enigma spector y el
conflicto de un bon halo casino royale
bebedor y mujeriego lo cual puede dejar
insatisfechos a muchos pero responde a
un personaje más de carne y hueso en un
mundo transformación es su cambio con
luchas del pasado confesiones y heridas
para un avance al futuro la gran
aportación de cary fukunaga al espía
creado por ian fleming sin olvidar que
el personaje es también vital para el
destino del mundo cuídense y muchísimas
gracias por la compañía gracias
sí
times
lo siento
[Música]
en life is the single
te sentiste
[Música]